him and charlie like confronted each  other he didn't want to  uh get in a fight with charlie so  he was like no not now and he walked  away and so  right now he was the bigger man and  that's good he's soft  he's soft he's like you're like ben's  over backwards for y'all  this is my daughter's wedding all right  going forward right now and y'all aren't  gonna like steal his money  nobody's killing anybody's money yeah  they don't pick the right place or the  right time to do any of their  [Music]  forget about it don't let it ruin your  evening  a part of me worries that  what if my family never gets along with  my husband like what if they always have  this constant tension and drama and  negativity like what if it doesn't end  i just i don't know  [Music]  you